yeah it's not done yet  but that's interesting that jan he did  take like one minute to double check  queen h1 queen a1 no i think he was not  at the board was he ah maybe he's  blocked by the board so i couldn't see i  would be very surprised if yam would  think  normally it would just blitz it out no  like that's more his style ambitious h3  not yeah there he doesn't spend a second  on me  and ding has seen enough  so we have the first victory of the  candidates first game which finished  and what a victory with the black pieces  against the favorite the world number  two  ding lyran yan nipponeshi the vice world  champion  shows he means business  that's impressive stuff  yeah he had uh  really played very well  congratulations goes to him probably we  might have some press conference right  or  some remarks by him after the game  yeah